in a small coastal town in what I am a
Prefecture Japan the traditional streets
and buildings hold one of the best-kept
secrets of Japanese gastronomy for it
was here in the 13th century that soy
sauce as we know it was first
established and produced this is Yuasa
the birthplace of soy sauce
[Music]
in 1254 a Buddhist monk arrived back
from his travels in China unsettled in
what they are a Prefecture he had
learned to the kind of missile made to
preserve some of vegetables and set to
work producing it in the neighboring
town of Yuasa where there was an
abundance of clear spring water
it was the liquid that collected in the
barrels of miso paste that became the
separate product we know as soy sauce
[Music]
soy sauce is made from four main
ingredients soybeans wheat salt and
water people like suckin Japanese
vinegar and Missal the fermentation
process is enabled by the use of a
starter called Koji the first stage in
making soy sauce is to mix steamed soy
beans and roasted wheat with the core G
mold the mixture is stored for four days
so the Koji can break down the sugars in
the grain to allow for fermentation
the core G base is next mix with salt
and water and put into huge wooden
barrels to ferment for between 18 months
and three and a half years the mash must
be mixed regularly by hand natural yeast
to the air and building act as
fermenting agent
after 18 months or more the fermented
mash is poured into cloth bags and
pressed to extract the liquid
this produces nama soy sauce
[Music]
the Nama soy sauce is heated in a
traditional iron pot over a fire of red
pine logs for half a day and the scum is
taken off by hand
[Music]
the result in soy sauce is then bottled
and shipped
[Music]
from humble beginnings in kazuo akiyama
soy sauce has become a global phenomenon
but its origins are protected and
maintained by a strong artisan tradition
unchanged in more than 750 years in the
ancient streets of USA
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]